foreign
s us up next in Lexington Kentucky
Mariella welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help today
yeah
there's a ton of things that the main
concern right now is my husband has been
lying to me and we've been working
through baby step number two but he's
been hiding like Financial
purchases that are really big or
how is he hiding him
um well this past week I found out that
the vehicle that we have been paying
hundreds of dollars from this month over
a thousand in repairs
um he had put a lien on it several
months ago so we couldn't even scrap it
this month
um which we're down to one car now
um and so that was one of the bigger
lives recently why do you put a lien on
his own car
um he's been
and he told me did he borrow against it
like the equity out of his car
that's my understanding like he got
a certain amount of money and then this
is when we were starting to work
together on the baby steps he said that
um we paid off some things using that
money because I was asking him where did
it go like why would you do that but he
said we he didn't feel like we had any
money and
um
so he went to one of those payday
lenders who said we'll give you three
thousand dollars but I'm holding the
title of your car like a Title Max looks
like an old Pizza Hut one of those
places
I just learned all of this not very long
ago and so we we had also
um had like similar things happen in our
relationship like with Lowe's
um he spent thousands that I didn't know
about there at Lowe's
Ryan
well I talked to them not too long ago
and because I received something in the
mail and that was how I found out in the
first place was the cards and was
originally primarily in my name because
we got this was white like years ago
when we first got married we got a
washer and dryer
then recently like he purchased a
lawnmower that was for him to use at his
grandparents house
um
and it was like six thousand dollars and
I didn't even know about it and then but
that's almost paid off that's the
promotional purchase
and there's about 9 000 in just random
less than 299
items they told me we need to come to
Jesus meeting tonight and we said
everything gets put on the table I would
say George before that walk her through
how she can pull her credit report and
find out what's out there yeah you can
pull your credit report for free
annually and it'll tell you every piece
of debt that is owed to your name
and he needs to do the same here's what
here's what I think Mariella can I just
be honest with you I don't want to be
alarmist but be honest with you
I think this is real bad is what I think
and either he is a bumbling goofball of
a ding dong
who just is walking through life
like a three-legged turtle
or
he has a very deceitful person who is
spending money on all kinds of things
and lying to his wife's face
and when that happens
it's very rare
that they're not hiding some sort of
addiction or some sort of other person
in the relationship
and I'm not telling you that to freak
you out I'm just telling you this is
what we do for a living
it is rare that somebody just keeps
blowing up money and spending six
thousand dollars
for a mower for your grandparent what
are you doing you know I mean that's
just Madness
and that tells me there's somebody who's
out of control
the
kind of
and he lost his grandfather who was
essentially his father figure a couple
years back and
um
I think part of it is like
in his mind he feels responsible to take
care of things for her totally get that
totally get that so I think that's kind
of where that came from and I was
getting to where I could forgive that
and I was we were working together I
thought so now I'm at square one again
because I'm like you tell me you're
telling me the truth and then you're not
well but there's also a difference
between I need to take care of my
grandmother
and I have to spit on and completely
dishonor my wife
you don't have to do one to do the other
I can completely honor my grandmother
and get on Craigslist and buy me a mower
that barely runs that will get the work
done
he did have a
Handler I believe
we all been together
five years approximately
at some point and that doesn't have to
be today
at some point you're gonna have to stop
defending him because you've been
defending him for a long long time right
why do you have an answer for everything
I'm calling out and George and I are
both husbands we know how this game
works
but you you're will you you keep
defending him and defending so you can
defend him all you want till the end of
time
but you can't breathe right now and
George and I can both hear it
he's broken your trust and that is the
foundation for any relationship and it's
going to take a long time to repair and
it's going to take even longer if he
continues to make these Financial
mistakes without talking to you and even
if he explains it you get a vote and
right now you haven't had a vote in this
relationship have you it's always been
him going well you don't understand I'm
doing the um I'll figure it out I got it
don't worry about it and you're going
along with it right
well before he had like complete control
over everything money-wise because I
didn't have a job because I had no that
is all kids no but now that's not hold
on he doesn't get the money because you
don't have a job my wife stays at home
she works some but she stays at home and
we do this thing together
that's not a reason
well now it's not that way
um and he did come to a point where he
said okay you have a turn and you try it
like he wanted to
let me see if I could do a better job
because we both knew it wasn't working
with him making the financial decisions
so
he's been in the driver's seat long
enough and he's been crashing the car in
fact he got rid of the car
one he went and bought another one on
credit
George was right George is 100 tonight
this ends
tonight you have to look across the
table and say
um you've been committing Financial
infidelity
you're violating our vows you're
cheating on me
and I think we get really obsessive in
our culture about Fidelity being one
thing and one thing only in its intimacy
with somebody else and I think
Fidelity's my commitment to you I'm all
in is way bigger than that
he's cheating on you he's stealing from
you he's lying to you and at some point
you got to say hopefully it's tonight
you put a put a piece of paper down and
you say this ends right now how much
money have you borrowed in our family's
name
how much do we owe and where is it
because man you made that one call to
Lowe's and you made that one other call
over here and you found out a whole
Litany of things you shouldn't have to
call Lowe's to figure out what your
husband has been up to no he should be
able to pull out the statement hand it
to you here's how here's how bad it is
but how dare he you take a turn at the
money and they keep keep borrowing more
money
that's wild
and I was gonna say I asked him the
other day like those kind of kinds of
questions are you cheating on me or what
other money has been borrowed and that
sort of thing and he did mention
another credit card not like thousands
or anything it was like 300 or something
but at this point at this point I don't
trust him I want to see his credit
report I don't either so I don't know
what to do but tell him to bring his
credit report to the table both go to
annualcreditreport.com you can pull it
for free both of you have to pull that
we're gonna look at this thing with a
fine-tooth comb lay out a plan and go if
you're not on board this is not going to
work we have to have a different
conversation
no more lies
cannot continue this relationship on a
throne of Lies it will not work so I'm
wishing you the best Marielle but you
got you got some more cut out for you
I'm so sorry you're going through this